Tom Bliss: Thank you so much awesome well i'm very excited to be here, and thanks to everybody for organizing this i'll just go ahead and get started so um yeah the focus that they will be sports tracking data,
Tom Bliss: Specifically really nfl tracking data,
Tom Bliss: And the big data will I listed my Twitter there at data with bliss feel free if there are any follow up questions to contact me there or and also I just tweeted out,
Tom Bliss: links to both the Congo, competition, the big data ball and the code that I will be sharing today, so if you want to follow along as we go, it should be easy to do so, so um,
Tom Bliss: First of all, what is sports tracking it, why is it important, why is it interesting um essentially what it is, is we know a sport, like, for example, the nfl here,
Tom Bliss: um we don't just record maybe what happened, the outcome of the play whether an nba maybe some made basket and baseball maybe it's a hit in hockey maybe it's a pass,
Tom Bliss: we're not we're not we're sort of going a step further and actually,
Tom Bliss: Throughout the entirety of a given play or series of plays where we're looking at the X, Y coordinates where the players actually are, and that can give us a lot more information, and this is relatively new data, a lot of sports analytics,
Tom Bliss: Like like other data sources might go back a little bit further, for example, there's nfl play by play data, going back to about 1999,
Tom Bliss: But this tracking data this this that sort of gives more information than just the what's going on in the play in terms of the outcome,
Tom Bliss: That that's actually giving the the coordinates of every player throughout the play that this is relatively new and another thing to notice it's not typically publicly available,
Tom Bliss: The nba has a little bit of it publicly available but outside of the big data model for nfl at least there really isn't any source that,
Tom Bliss: I know of that that's publicly available and last thing I was going to sort of, say, before I move on was,
Tom Bliss: there's sort of two types of tracking data, you can use video, which is is used in in other leagues, to the nba and nhl and soccer where maybe you're,
Tom Bliss: You use the same broadcast you see the video and you,
Tom Bliss: convert the images of the video into X, Y coordinates or what the nfl does is they use rf ID chip so literal radio chips that are going to be in the shoulder pads of every single player and in the ball,
Tom Bliss: On that relays to a sort of a source radio and that will you it'll constantly be measuring where the players are throughout the entirety of the play so so that's what nfl tracking it is based on the these radio coordinates and that's sort of what we're going to be discussing today,
Tom Bliss: So next, what is the big data so it's an online free to sign up competition, I encourage everybody who's interested after this to look at it think about signing up,
Tom Bliss: If the focus is on this nfl tracking data that that i'm discussing and the goal is, we give folks the data they have an opportunity to analyze it create new metrics do fun stuff visualize it,
Tom Bliss: And typically what it also like as the League we get to see a lot more cool new content and also as a league it sort of provides a pipeline for nfl team hires and and honestly also other sports team hires,
Tom Bliss: It shows others that you have this skills to work with this this complex data and a lot of teams are sort of asking for this and it's a good way to to show off your skills and provide new contacts and create some cool stuff,
Tom Bliss: This is a very, very general timeline of what the big data will typically is typically the whoops i'm so sorry typically the,
Tom Bliss: It starts in September, October the submission deadline is November to January, then there's judging the winners are announced and,
Tom Bliss: we're run trouble will happen this year with with coven but typically the winners have presented in the past, at the nfl scouting combine February, March and,
Tom Bliss: Eventually the work is submitted into production by teams by the League and it becomes useful,
Tom Bliss: So yeah currently we're in the middle of the 2022 big data bowl which launched in late September and we'll go through January so definitely not too late to sign up if If those are interested so here's a quick overview of what the big data model,
Tom Bliss: competitions have looked like in the past we've had three in the past where we're currently in the middle of our fourth the first big data bowl what was was fairly open ended,
Tom Bliss: We shared a bunch of tracking data, and we were asking folks to look at stuff involving route combinations so sort of power receiver might run to try to get open rule changes and,
Tom Bliss: Which how the rules, the Games will be in their speed on the second one and 2020 where the focus was expected rushing yards,
Tom Bliss: And I don't know if anyone has seen the the rush yards over expectation metric that's something that that stem from the big data double and, last year we were looking at the secondary and so that's defensive players and coverage trying to prevent,
Tom Bliss: other players from from catching so so all three years have been very cool a lot of very good stuff is come out of each of them and,
Tom Bliss: So it's been really fun so far um and I guess the other thing I would like to note is each year, we have more sort of we have a lot of entrance we're getting more entrance,
Tom Bliss: lot more attendees it's growing and Racine nfl hires each year, the first year we had 11 and three and seven there's a cash prize of it goes to the winner,
Tom Bliss: A lot of countries are participating, for example in 2020 or 32 different countries,
Tom Bliss: The reason 2020 maybe got a little bit more than the other years is there was this was sort of a traditional kind of competition, the sense that there was one metric where,
Tom Bliss: Other years it was more open ended, and it was more submission based and that's that's how it works this year but yeah participants we get a lot of participants and typically we see samantha hires from it,
Tom Bliss: So my final slide as I do this brief overview i'm gonna talk about the 2022 big data well that's the one that's going on today again the September to January and,
Tom Bliss: Essentially, what what participants are asked to submit is a cargo notebook that will have be that that will show sort of a analysis results,
Tom Bliss: The goal is to submit a paper that that gives information that someone can read and learn something new and the theme is nfl special teams plays,
Tom Bliss: Which that includes kickoffs field goals punts as opposed to offensive and defensive plays and also, we also are including some external data which which comes from pro football focus,
Tom Bliss: So this is the first year, where we actually go across three years, which is pretty cool and there's a lot of cool data that we're sharing and, obviously, you can see, on Twitter, you can see right here, we encourage people to check it out@geico,com slash public data by 2022,
Tom Bliss: um so with that,
Tom Bliss: i'm going to share a quick animation of what this data looks like and then I think we're going to take a quick pause for for questions after I show this animation before I get into the code,
Tom Bliss: So i'm right here we're going to look at a video of some data that we could see during that that's included in the nfl big data bl,
Tom Bliss: um it's some tracking data, involving a kickoff play by the bears in the Vikings and i'm going to show to show what it what the video looks like and what the actual play looks like so as you can see, this is before the video starts, we have some players lined up,
Tom Bliss: And they align with the players lined up there, so the players in the video in white that's the Vikings there were white here and,
Tom Bliss: Players in dark blue, which are the bears are here so i'm going to play the animation in the video, at the same time, and this is just to give a sense of,
Tom Bliss: really what we're doing is we're just taking the video we're taking what actually is happening in the game,
Tom Bliss: And we're just translating it to data to X, Y coordinate, so we can analyze players in place, so I guess the point at the same time, so you can see in the video it's moving in the ball,
Tom Bliss: see another player has the ball and he's running up the field and the video is not working, sometimes this happens, but,
Tom Bliss: You can see now that the player with the balls is running towards the end zone, and you can see, on the video and in the animation, so this is just a way to to analyze what's actually happening, the game, and we now have X, Y coordinates it just it's a good way to see,
Tom Bliss: How, everything is working and it's it's efficient it's easier than just,
Tom Bliss: watching every play per se so with that i'm going to do a quick break for for questions and then afterwards i'm going to get into the code,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thanks so much time I just took a quick look at this slide Oh, and I don't see any specific questions on the big data bowl yet i'm going to check again but feel free to raise your hand and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I can turn on the ability for people to unmute themselves for a second as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And we can also see have questions for this till the end as well if they yeah,
Tom Bliss: yeah that's fine yeah so if there aren't any question, what is the sampling rate for the data that's a great question so,
Tom Bliss: 10 times,
Tom Bliss: A second um,
Tom Bliss: We do a reading so every 10th of a second,
Tom Bliss: cool all right well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): A few one other question was when will the database for 2023 begin,
Tom Bliss: Yes, so um,
Tom Bliss: I would assume September, October 2022 i'm just sort of towards the beginning of the nfl season,
Tom Bliss: For the 2022 season, but again I there's still plenty of time left for for this big data, so if you're interested, maybe, maybe,
Tom Bliss: Your maybe less busy during that time so that might make more sense, but if you're interested I highly encourage you to still try to check it out there's plenty of time still to get a submission,
Tom Bliss: is the reason why the data,
Tom Bliss: isn't yeah that the data is,
Tom Bliss: The nfl,
Tom Bliss: doesn't want to share the data its proprietary part of it is teams have access to, and you don't want to you, it just doesn't make sense to sort of give it away to everybody outside of this event so maybe i'm not the best person to answer that question may be,
Tom Bliss: But yeah we don't share it outside of ignitable what is the error um I don't know if there's like a met like a like a rms see I can give you, but certainly there are some places where there is there are mistakes um sometimes when the balls punted and tie up,
Tom Bliss: might lose a little bit of connection to the radios that are that are stationary I don't know if radios they were but it might may be a little bit harder to read, where exactly it is,
Tom Bliss: So, so that that's a possibility of air typically though for the big data, but most of the air written plays are removed so everything should be good,
Tom Bliss: I guess maybe a better way that we could say, is, I think it's pretty accurate to I believe it's six inches or something it's pretty close like it's it's at least less than a foot yeah,
Tom Bliss: um that seems yeah so it's less than a foot of air typically so so that's it's it's pretty good in that regard,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome that there's a few other questions around like specific packages that I think might be helpful to cover maybe after the next part as well,
Tom Bliss: Okay yeah that sounds good, so all i'll jump in to my code,
Tom Bliss: If no one else has any questions so yeah i'm sharing this from Cabo and unfortunately I couldn't figure out a way to make it bigger So hopefully this is readable for everybody,
Tom Bliss: If it's not like I can zoom in but i'm hoping it's everyone is able to read it,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): looks good to me,
Tom Bliss: Okay, good so,
Tom Bliss: uh the first code sample i'm going to do in this is stuff that publicly shared before we're going to discuss using the big data data,
Tom Bliss: to analyze kick attempt to offset from Center, which is a metric that we're creating and you can only really create with the tracking data so,
Tom Bliss: The first question is like what it what exactly is this metric so as far as football fans would know kickers are part of it is your field goal kicker will try to kick a ball in between the field goal posts,
Tom Bliss: As it, as you can see in this image, right here on the goal would be to make it inside and depending on whether it's an extra point or a field goal it's either three or one point that's not necessarily relevant here,
Tom Bliss: But as you try to make it through, as you might as you're if you're kicking in let's say a soccer ball or a hockey Puck assuming maybe there's no goalie there but,
Tom Bliss: You try to get it as centered as possible, because that would increase your chance of making it so what we're doing here is we're going to measure how,
Tom Bliss: Close the Center as as the ball goes to the uprights a typical field goal kicker might be and that's just a way for us to say who's the most accurate who's best that,
Tom Bliss: Getting it right in between the posts, maybe there's also an element of luck, maybe one player my one kicker might be,
Tom Bliss: 90% maybe 90% of the field goals, but a lot of their field goals were barely where another player was kicking 89% and all their field goals were completely in and that just as a way to say, maybe,
Tom Bliss: there's a little bit of luck going on here and in the future, we might expect the other kicker to be doing better, so this is just a way to measure kicker skill looking at at that that offset from Center,
Tom Bliss: So we're going to load up some libraries tidy verse, of course,
Tom Bliss: animate we're going to animate some stuff and we're gonna make a rich plot so nothing, nothing too crazy in terms of packages to start,
Tom Bliss: we're going to load in plays data plays data that's you're going to see this in every sport it's sort of like a description of what's going on on a given play in football it's a very,
Tom Bliss: sort of broken up sport in the sense that you're playing and then you're not playing and you're not so each of the each row represents,
Tom Bliss: A given play a given series of like a snap and then what happens after the snap players again that that might be that you're going to see that in every sport every sport as players, and this is just,
Tom Bliss: who they are, so we look at the head of the players variable and we just have an ID we have their name, we have some other information really we're just going to look at where we're going to revert we care about the ID and the name,
Tom Bliss: Or the College name, but the idea and the the the display name, which is their their actual name is the plays variable it's a game idea play ID of quarter down distance information like that,
Tom Bliss: Okay cool now we're going to load in the tracking data and the tracking data is very big which makes sense here you have,
Tom Bliss: Your measuring it every 10th of a second, and you have a row for each player on each 10th of a second for each play so it's going to be very large you're going to there's 11 players per team and the ball,
Tom Bliss: So for each 10th of a second you're gonna have 23 and typical plays will last like four to six seconds so,
Tom Bliss: And there's also some time immediately after and immediately before the play so it grows really quickly so that's why we have a little bit simpler lovely because it's it's big data so we're going to load it in,
Tom Bliss: we're gonna look at the head and, as you can see, we have a time we have an x we have a y coordinate, we have an nfl ID which we can match the players and,
Tom Bliss: We have a game it in a play ID which we can match the plays and frame ID which is sort of like what frame, it is you can match it across different players on a given play some of these other variables we're we're not going to use here, we might use the next one SS speed is acceleration,
Tom Bliss: So we're, this is what the data we're going to be working with looks like,
Tom Bliss: So next week we're going to think about cleaning the data so um one thing to note is and i'm going to show you a map of what the data looks like,
Tom Bliss: We have an x and a y, and this is just something that this is an nfl field um the X coordinate goes from end zone, the end zone, the y coordinate goes from one side of the field across the other side of the field,
Tom Bliss: And this is a way to look at it so 00 is the corner of the home end zone where 01 2120 zero is the corner of the visitor end zone so,
Tom Bliss: Football fields 100 yards between the end zones you Jen zone is 10 yards each one thing to note and that's what we're about to do, and the next part of code,
Tom Bliss: Because each team will change sides at the end of each quarter the,
Tom Bliss: Sometimes the offense and the kicker will be kicking in one direction, sometimes they'll be kicking in the other direction, so, as you can see, like,
Tom Bliss: The the X and the y coordinates don't necessarily change with the WHO has the ball which direction they're going which direction they're kicking,
Tom Bliss: So one thing that it's important to do is to check the play direction that's the direction that the team is kicking,
Tom Bliss: or in this case, in this case kicking or the direction the offense is going and flipping it so that way it's consistent,
Tom Bliss: So if you're kicking a field goal you're never going to be you're always gonna be kicking a field goal, the same direction in the coordinates,
Tom Bliss: So we're flipping it so that way, no matter what the team will be kicking this way,
Tom Bliss: that's somewhat arbitrary, we could say they're always kicking this way, but just to keep it consistent we don't want,
Tom Bliss: A field goal kicker to be kicking towards this ends on appeal or kicking towards the end zone to look totally different we want to be able to compare them apples to apples since they're essentially the same,
Tom Bliss: So we do that flip we take the tracking data we look at we filter for when the the it's the football the tracking data also contains players in this case, we only care about the football,
Tom Bliss: Although we're interested in who's kicking it we're not we're really just kick curious about the directory not what the kicker is doing it as they kick it we don't we don't really care about that,
Tom Bliss: we're taking the football we're we're looking at the the X, coordinate and we're seeing Okay, where we want plays where the lag of X the play,
Tom Bliss: Previously, and before I let me know that i'm grouping by game and play so that way we're only looking at specific for a given game and given playing or arranging by the game play in the frame so that way we're making sure we're looking in order so we're filtering for plays where,
Tom Bliss: you're you're you have passed the 120 mark, but your previous the previous X was before the 120 mark,
Tom Bliss: So we're really started to look at the map we're really looking right back here and that's where the upgrade is located,
Tom Bliss: we're filtering for the spot right when they cross this back end zone right when they would be crossing the uprights,
Tom Bliss: we're selecting the first occurrence, just in case, maybe it rolls after we don't want any weirdness going on,
Tom Bliss: And then we're calculating the key metric here, which is offset from Center so we're taking the y variable the crossfield variable and we're figuring out the difference between it,
Tom Bliss: And the the Center which,
Tom Bliss: We kind of see as as the goal we want an ideal kick will be just down the middle as they might say so,
Tom Bliss: we're taking the difference between where that why variable is Center,
Tom Bliss: So, then, for each game and each player only selecting these variables, we have the offset from Center so an ideal offset from Center would be zero,
Tom Bliss: A bad offset from Center might be like 10 the the goalposts are about or I think 18 and a half feet apart, all these coordinates are in yards, which is the coordinates of football, so I think about six points, something is the length of the,
Tom Bliss: uprights so if you're outside of 3,34 3,5 and above about your product to be missing the kick so that that's not good, you want to be making and you want to be making it just,
Tom Bliss: So we're merging it to the plays variable we're only looking at plays when there's a field goal attempt i'm removing plays when the field goal attempt we're sure,
Tom Bliss: we're looking at the yard from the end zone, just so we have a sense of how far was this kit we don't want, we want to,
Tom Bliss: Is if you're kicking very close if it's an easy kick we want to treat them differently than if you're coming from a very far distance,
Tom Bliss: And so we're calculating the kick length, which is the yards from the end zone, plus 18 which takes into account the link to the end zone and some other factors,
Tom Bliss: rejoining the players, so that way, we have the names are joining this this this metric that we had so now we're only on look at what we're interested we're going to look at the game ID the play ID the name of the kicker,
Tom Bliss: How long would kick the field goal kick was and what the offset from centers and that's that come variable so we know that,
Tom Bliss: yeah kicking a 50 yard field over sticking a 20 yard field goal for those of you know football those those are very different in difficulty, so we want to make sure when we're looking at this opposite from Center variable we're being fair,
Tom Bliss: So this is what our final very final thing looks like we have game ID play ID we have a display name, we have a kick length, we have offset from Center and we have a description of what happened,
Tom Bliss: Okay cool so before we sort of get into visualizing and figuring out who's the best miss metric it's ideal to animate a player to,
Tom Bliss: So we're going to use this field from Marshall thurman's github we're going to just select a random play Oh, I guess we're selecting a play with the minimum opposite from Center to give an example, this is one where it was was a really,
Tom Bliss: Like a very perfect kick and we're joining that to the tracking just the select that one out,
Tom Bliss: i'm not going to go too deep into all these sort of colors essentially i'm setting a lot of colors and width just so i'm to make sure that field looks looks good i'm setting the plot titles, the play description which is, which is this variable just sort of saying what happened,
Tom Bliss: And yeah i'm gonna do an animation using tg plot and DG field i'm i'm adding a segment for the uprights,
Tom Bliss: So i'm going to animate each point and it's going to look, similar to what we saw previously what right before I took the first break,
Tom Bliss: we're going to hit add some points and we're going to animate what the the players look like and the ball, as this this field goal goes in using GM point and adding some colors and some text for the Jersey numbers, so this is what it looks like um so we see,
Tom Bliss: This is what this was the kick with the lowest offset from Center so the best metric and is a 50 yard field goal, I think the other one read yep so we're looking at your bill goes on here so as you can see,
Tom Bliss: The field look here gets it, and if you look right there looks perfectly just down the middle, this is about as in between those uprights, as you can get so that's what we're saying is what we see as an ideal kick,
Tom Bliss: We now can animate one, but instead look at the Max offset from Center when looking at a 50 yard kick so this one might be the one that had the That was the worst in terms of being able to kick it between,
Tom Bliss: um so as you can see, this one wasn't really that close it was a couple yards out of the uprights it wasn't made it was not a good kick,
Tom Bliss: and
Tom Bliss: as compared to this one that was just done, the middle, which was perfect this one was,
Tom Bliss: not good, and I mean another thing you can think of is if they're going to miss it, you probably feel a little bit more promise with their performance if they're missing it just outside this one that you missed these meet outside,
Tom Bliss: Okay cool so we're going to visualize this metric by kicker so as we saw before we are able to emerge who's kicking on a given play to this metric,
Tom Bliss: And that way, we have a sense of who's who's doing wellness metric and, for this will just look at all kicks between 30 and 40 yards just because there's the biggest sample size there and,
Tom Bliss: We don't we again we don't want to use a kick length, that is, you know we don't want to,
Tom Bliss: vary by kick length is maybe some kickers are just kicking easier field goals we don't want to give them the benefit of the doubt,
Tom Bliss: There so we're grouping by the display name, which is the name of the kicker we're limiting for only kickers who have 75 plus attempts we don't want to have a kicker who had one attempt that was perfect and be showing him as a,
Tom Bliss: As the best when we know that maybe he wouldn't be as good at the end, a better a bigger sample size so,
Tom Bliss: we're grouping by that we're filtering for a sample size of 75 or more and we're calculating the average offset from Center,
Tom Bliss: una GG plot or in a bar plot and we're setting the theme labels other stuff and and now look at this, we have a plot that will give us the the kicker average offset from Center i'm,
Tom Bliss: ordered from the best kicker to the worst kicker and for those of you who know nfl football it's probably not a surprise that justin Tucker is seen as the best kicker he's he's universally seen as probably probably the best kicker,
Tom Bliss: Today, and then certainly over 2018 to 2020 I think a lot of people would would say he's probably the best kicker over that time i'm the worst kicker is Adam planetary and, although he historically was a very good kicker is,
Tom Bliss: season and his 2018 season, I think his last two were probably not as best so that's why you might be not as high as metric compared to some other so again, we can compare and,
Tom Bliss: All the on average they're all making money, and that makes sense because typical kicker today is probably making 80 90%,
Tom Bliss: On the end because it was greater than three maybe we could say, maybe on average they're missing, but on average it's it's in between the upgrades but they vary in terms of of how,
Tom Bliss: Close to right down the middle, they are Tucker and surprisingly, is the best and then you see a lot sort of in the middle and he's the best by a wide margin which, which also would agree with intuition,
Tom Bliss: we're going to take this exact same data and look at it as a rich plot as a series of density plots,
Tom Bliss: That will give us a little bit more information, as opposed to a bar, which is just one average, we can we can see, maybe it's maybe,
Tom Bliss: Some kickers are just wild there sometimes very good sometimes very bad so they look average maybe some kickers are,
Tom Bliss: Just typically right at a certain range and looking at a densely plot will will give us a sense of whether this is a consistent,
Tom Bliss: I could go that consistently is that, where it's at or or maybe he is sometimes is right on the money, sometimes is a little bit off so,
Tom Bliss: we're going to use GM density averages from the GG ridges package to to plot this, and again I ordered the exact same way by smallest average but yeah Tucker, we can see, it is fairly consistent and Adam monetary,
Tom Bliss: He probably has one of the flattest distribution sometimes he was really good mentors really bad,
Tom Bliss: And that sort of agrees with with what we saw and 2019 he wasn't very good at all, he was decent um so So this is the first,
Tom Bliss: code that i'm going to share the second one, I might go through a little bit quicker, but maybe maybe I might stop for questions here but also we can people can ask at the end again so does anyone have any questions,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): start with,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Reading a few from from slide Oh, and just a reminder if if you don't mind if you're putting questions in the zoom chat I love to see them there too, I just want to make sure I don't miss any if you don't mind copying them over to slide oh,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But one of the questions it's what are some preferred packages for best dealing with X by data,
Tom Bliss: yeah um so,
Tom Bliss: I mean,
Tom Bliss: I typically,
Tom Bliss: just use the tidy verse metrics but I definitely know that there are some that are pretty good I know Ben baldwin has a package and I can't think of it off the top my head, but he has a package that does some data cleaning for,
Tom Bliss: Next gen stats data such as what you might see in the big data model and that's something I would suggest,
Tom Bliss: To just start but I mean there's a lot of different ways to tackle it it really depends on what you're doing, and there are some spatial packages that sometimes would make sense if you're doing a specific thing but,
Tom Bliss: Sometimes typically what I do is I just use tidy verse and,
Tom Bliss: I guess, I would also recommend some animation packages, such as GG animate just because with this data,
Tom Bliss: it's hard to even know what's going on, even if you're looking at I like to use view sometimes just look at what data i'm dealing with,
Tom Bliss: um even that sometimes is really difficult because there's so much going on, so always animating the using some sort of animation facts to animate the data goes leaps and bounds in terms of understanding what's going on,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome and one other question is what insights are you most interested in with this year's competition,
Tom Bliss: You know that that's a great question I don't know if there's,
Tom Bliss: Obviously, the theme is special teams, the advice I would give is not necessarily any specific insight, but if you're going to do an insight,
Tom Bliss: If you're going to participate, I would suggest, rather than trying to solve 10 problems at once and say,
Tom Bliss: here's a metric that looks at punters on punk plays and here's another metric that looks at field goal kickers and here's another plate, it looks at kickoff here's like like a metric that,
Tom Bliss: a bunch of metrics for a bunch of different things I would highly suggest looking at one specific player and,
Tom Bliss: Or what no one wants to position one specific position on the play type and really digging deep,
Tom Bliss: Definitely teams who and analytics staffers from teams are going to be the judges, so those that are the judges definitely get gain a lot more when it's something really in depth that solves one issue, rather than trying to solve special teams,
Tom Bliss: With tracking data all in one submission, so I would just suggest,
Tom Bliss: Whatever you do and there's plenty of things you can look at with punting kicking,
Tom Bliss: Honestly, if it, even if it seems simple that that can go leaps and bounds if it's done well just just don't do don't try to tackle every single problem just find something that you're interested in and that you can do well and tackle that really, really well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So it's okay to ask if,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): You can, if it's okay to ask a few more now,
Tom Bliss: yeah yes sure are there, are there any specific to this,
Tom Bliss: One, otherwise I can pick him jump to the next,
Tom Bliss: thing which i'll probably go through a little bit faster maybe skip the cleaning steps and just focus on the results,
Mitch Tanney: Time there's been quite a bit of discussion, the chat about the Z coordinate as especially as it relates to,
Mitch Tanney: The edge that you created, can you talk a little bit about what's available what isn't available for that,
Tom Bliss: yeah so they're the unfortunately we,
Tom Bliss: don't measure the,
Tom Bliss: Z coordinate arm with with our tracking data currently um and, but I would say there are definitely ways to figure it out, whether it be looking at the event data so that there's events that are tagged like field goal kick field goal make field goal miss or kickoff land,
Tom Bliss: That, as well as you could use the pfs hang time data to get a sense of when it landed arm, so I would say that there are certainly ways to to use,
Tom Bliss: That to infer the Z coordinate you know the speed, you know how long it was in the air, you know where it landed, you can get a sense of what the Z coordinate is using and i'm a physics person, so I like physics, a lot so using kinematics,
Tom Bliss: As and I think there has been some work on that maybe in previous big data bubbles but definitely that's something that that could be inferred using some of the other variables, but unfortunately it's not measured on on site,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, I, I see a few people have put their their name and they asked a question on slide oh so i'd love to like turn the MIC over to you to have you ask those if that's okay,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Emily I see you asked a question about different factors and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): pertaining to the kicker would you like to ask that one line,
Amelia Probst: Sure um I,
Amelia Probst: I was just curious if how you thought about using age as a factor in these kickers and how they perform,
Tom Bliss: You know i'm,
Tom Bliss: dead, not in this specific analysis but that's definitely something that could be explored and maybe, especially, although it's only three years,
Tom Bliss: Which maybe isn't a huge sample size of yours, this is the first time, when we have multiple years of,
Tom Bliss: Data so maybe that is something to look at, but yeah that definitely something that you should use think about exploring and you have the birth dates from the the players data so so you should you should feel free to explore that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So my Brian I see you had a Brian philco had another question as well, if I could pass the MIC over to you,
Bryan Filker: yeah, of course, yes i'm just curious on factors such as like you know wind direction and speed those kind of things you're trying to find like a uniformity, you know, in setting the kick direction,
Bryan Filker: Different stadium constructs and now I always think of you know phil Dawson always mentioned the Cleveland browns how we had a special flag installed, so you can see the wind direction wind speed to factor into this case is that taken in consideration at all,
Tom Bliss: yeah so so again, not for this analysis and,
Tom Bliss: This was sort of built to get people started a definitely I would highly suggest if you're going to look at,
Tom Bliss: Look at that and you're interested in whether stuff definitely go for it um I posted on the cargo website so external data for this competition is totally free to use as long as it's publicly available to everybody for free,
Tom Bliss: So I would I would highly encourage you to seek out whether it I posted some on the capital side and tweeted some and it's also on my github,
Tom Bliss: But also there, there are plenty of other sources, you can use for weather data, so if you feel free to use it um and I would, if you are participating in that you feel you want to use that I would I would highly encourage you to do so,
Thanks,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So much, I know that you're monitoring the slide oh as well, and just wanted to check, are there any other questions you think we should ask now,
Mitch Tanney: One of the questions was about statistical modeling techniques and Tom can you maybe i'll just throw my two cents in here to kind of underscore something that you said,
Mitch Tanney: about finding something particular and doing it really well so just as what you just described, for instance didn't necessarily include any sort of sophisticated,
Mitch Tanney: modeling technique it required really good intuition of understanding of the sport and some coordinate understanding coordinate information and you're able to see a really meaningful,
Mitch Tanney: metric as the output so For those of you who are maybe thinking, this is a mountain of data i'm going to apply the super sophisticated modeling technique,
Mitch Tanney: By all means have there's you know there's certainly things to do there, but at the same time, really good intuition and understanding of the game and just some core understanding coordinate information, you can have some really meaningful output as well,
Tom Bliss: yeah absolutely absolutely,
Tom Bliss: I would, I would echo that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome thanks Tom i'll,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): pass it back over to you to continue the presentation and we'll save the rest for them to,
Tom Bliss: Perfect perfect yes so i'm i'm probably just gonna skip the cleaning the reading data for the second,
Tom Bliss: thing but i'll briefly go over what what the metrics about and talk about the modeling techniques,
Tom Bliss: So another thing that another DEMO that we put together we looked at speed on kickoff plays so um the kickoff special team special teams are planted the sprint down the field,
Tom Bliss: Try to take off to the end zone and try to make a tackle and they try to run as fast as possible, to prevent the the return team from from,
Tom Bliss: gain yards so For those of you know football, you know the kickoff so essentially at when the the kicker kicks it off,
Tom Bliss: All the other members of the the kickoff team or or sprinting as fast as possible, one thing that we can look at is what is their speed how fast do they go,
Tom Bliss: On these plays um so i'm going to skip the the cleaning and the reading, although that those are very important to sort of talking about a type of type of model that,
Tom Bliss: We like to use at the League and it's also just something that applies here so essentially we assume the data is already been cleaned,
Tom Bliss: Basically, what we have is, we have a game ID play ID nfl ID so the given player on the kickoff team and their Max speed during the play and we're going to try to model that,
Tom Bliss: And also, we also have surface, which were between merge which, which is also part of it so,
Tom Bliss: we're going to create a mixed effects model and a mixed effects model sort of to account for lack of independence among observations,
Tom Bliss: We assume that each player is sort of from the same population of players and no player is going to be drastically faster than another, so we assume that each player is from a distribution and,
Tom Bliss: As they sprint more,
Tom Bliss: As we get more observations we sort of have more of a post theory and can assume where that player might be,
Tom Bliss: If they have few observations we assume that they're probably close to the overall league me in terms of speed so we're just modeling the Max speed, taking into account the nfl ID and the service,
Tom Bliss: um so again i'll try to go a little bit quickly through this, we have a model that takes into account assume players are random effect, meaning,
Tom Bliss: If we have a lot of information about them we're going to sort of believe what they what the information says otherwise if they have one observation,
Tom Bliss: We were going to assume that they're probably closer to the mean and not just to prevent a player with one really good observation to be,
Tom Bliss: leaps and bounds better than a player, with very few and if we were to do a sort of a dummy variable or factor variable for each enough ID we just had we'd probably overfit and have a ton of variables, so this is just a way to have sort of a value for each enough ID and not overfit,
Tom Bliss: So we're gonna look at the summary of the model,
Tom Bliss: We have fixed effects, which are the surface that's a pretty typical thing that treats us sort of like a normal factor type variable and then we have the nfl ID, which is the intercept,
Tom Bliss: That that's again where we're assuming it's from a,
Tom Bliss: Population where all the players from the population are more or less the same and we'll have more or less the same speed,
Tom Bliss: We can plot the the the the results, the model sort of the player effects and, again, this is just to take into account the fact that,
Tom Bliss: The players will have a Max speed effect,
Tom Bliss: That is based on the fact that they're running across different surfaces and that's Another advantage of it and i'm realism, I explained, this will be the,
Tom Bliss: each player, will have an effect that is based upon how they've done across different services, but this modeling technique takes into account each surface, so perhaps it's really hard to run fast on grass um players that run fast on grass, will have an adjustment to their,
Tom Bliss: coefficient it's it's kind of like any other model where your each sort of variable will take each other into account in order to have a,
Tom Bliss: value that that makes sense, so,
Tom Bliss: What we did based on taking into account the surface figuring out what the effect or the intercept will be for each nfl ID from in terms of figuring out what their Max speed will be,
Tom Bliss: We have player effects that can kind of be thought of as plus or minus what you might expect, compared to the average player on the average surface, so the thought is matt Cole,
Tom Bliss: Will typically be about 1,7 yards per second faster than the average kickoff coverage player on the average surface,
Tom Bliss: This is the top 25 of the of all the players in this effect so y axis player name X axis is that plus or minus player, back then, we have the top 25 in this metric so matt call,
Tom Bliss: Is the fast this were devin do renee is the slowest of the top 25 or so on the top 25, so this is just a way for us to take into account surface and and really measure what we how well we expect these players to do, compared to the average player,
Tom Bliss: This is the, this is what the the entire population looks like of these player effects so it's a left skewed distribution with mean zero,
Tom Bliss: Standard deviation around one arm and,
Tom Bliss: They were like around point five, and the distribution will will will give us information on what what this what this looks like and you can see that the difference between the best plan, the worst player isn't necessarily that that large it's about two yards per second,
Tom Bliss: The last thing that i'm going to sort of touch with this part of the presentation is one thing that I would highly suggest people do if they are,
Tom Bliss: playing on participating in the big data bowl is to analyze a model stability, to make sure that Okay, if this model predicts well for,
Tom Bliss: The first season, how will do in the second season and or if this model predicts well for the beginning of the season, how it will do for the end of the season, we don't want to,
Tom Bliss: it's a way to make sure that your results are making sense and are picking up on something so one thing that we can do here is, we can do the exact same process before to get the,
Tom Bliss: player effects but do one model that is only weeks one to eight do another model that is only weeks nine to 17 and and again we have the nfl ID the display name and they're backed up ID display name, in effect, so we have two different models only using subsets of the data,
Tom Bliss: and
Tom Bliss: We can merge them together and compare them using a sort of an X, Y plot this red line is is y equals one, so if everything perfectly goes through those that line, then that means we have a perfect fit,
Tom Bliss: If everything, if anything, is a little bit off um then then we're we're not getting a perfect fit,
Tom Bliss: um basically based on the fact that we sort of see obviously trade flowers here at the bottom seems a little bit off,
Tom Bliss: Basically, since we were seen a pretty good fit line we feel pretty confident,
Tom Bliss: um,
Tom Bliss: And then we can do that, we can remove the outliers feel a little bit better um yes So then, when you look at the R squared um but,
Tom Bliss: yeah This is just two things that I would say to take away from this part is just one really analyzing stability is a good way to make sure your model is,
Tom Bliss: is doing what you would you hope it does and to definitely there's a lot of different modeling techniques to look at here,
Tom Bliss: and definitely take into account if you're going to do something with a bunch of players i'm,
Tom Bliss: doing a model with 300 different players each having their own variable can be difficult, especially because each of them are going to have different number of observations will be playing different number of plays,
Tom Bliss: will have different roles there'll be on different teams so so really thinking about that stuff is important,
Tom Bliss: So yeah i'll pause again and I understand I probably went through this section a little bit fast so, but hopefully people were able to catch stuff but i'll pause again and I can answer some questions, I can answer through,
Tom Bliss: Hopefully, I won't get kicked out of the room that i'm in and if I do i'll just have to turn off video for a second and jump back in answering questions,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you so much, Tom that's awesome and yeah no worries, if you have to turn off video and run to another room, thank you for taking the extra time,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And I see there's a anonymous question that we may have touched, I think you touched on this one already is environmental data included are allowed in this big data,
Tom Bliss: yeah it's not necessarily included with what we're providing but it's certainly allowed as long as it's publicly available free to haul um so so definitely allowed if you can find something that you want to use,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome josh goldberg I see you had asked a question and slide oh,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Around peak age, would you want to ask that question live or add any other any context,
Josh Goldberg: i'm sure um I think amelia kind of had a similar question to before, but I was just curious if you had looked into any of the kind of distribution for how the,
Josh Goldberg: The metric offset by Center what that looks like for players over the course of their career that kind of visit, which is a certain peak ah to when players are you know, have the lowest math absolute value they're kind of what that looks like,
Tom Bliss: yeah no i'm I have not, but really I would just say that that's a great big data project if somebody wants to take,
Tom Bliss: What what I was doing there and take it a step further,
Tom Bliss: We really like like like the only the data we provided was 2018 to 20 but honest that's essentially all the data that we have the week have is that's when it was it was really being recorded so,
Tom Bliss: Realistically, know I probably the coolest thing about this data is answering questions because it's so new you might be one of the first people, if not the first people person to answer that question so,
Tom Bliss: No, I didn't look at it in this analysis, but I would highly recommend anyone who's interested in the big data to look at that, so I think that'd be a cool project,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Okay, thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): let's see going over to slide out for the X, Y coordinators, how does it work with with sidelines and zach I see you actually asked this question, if you want to jump in and add some context there,
Zac Rogers: yeah I was looking mainly looking at kick returns and punt returns,
Zac Rogers: And, of course, quite often they run it over to the sideline I see that it starts with zero there on the sideline and bridging disgrace into negative coordinates,
Tom Bliss: yeah that's exactly right, so if your return on you run out if this mouse is the return you're running out, right here you're probably going to be around like negative one negative two and then, if you go above it you're going to be about the p three and a third, which is where the,
Tom Bliss: field ends it'll just be about two to three and a third and you're out of your own end zone you'll be negative and you're above 128 will be,
Zac Rogers: Perfect Thank you very much yep,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Absolutely, thank you and I see a few people had asked questions about where the data is, and also how to access the code and Mitch had shared the link in the chat window, so you can access that there,
Tom Bliss: yeah and I tweeted out the code that I shared, as well as the link to the big data will for my Twitter at data with bliss so feel free to go on there, and all those links are going to be available and yet you can also just Google cargo big data by 2022 all this will will show up,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome and there's a broad question as well, which I think is is awesome to ask all of our speakers, but they asked what is the best advice or courses for someone who has little understanding and are to develop better skills,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And everybody in the audience feel free to share examples in the chat as well, but i'll ask you this first time,
Tom Bliss: yeah, so I would say a lot of how I learned are was just um I did a lot of learning sort of by doing and,
Tom Bliss: Maybe that hopefully that that helps the question you, that is the question completely because I don't know if I have a specific tutorial or anything that I lent on,
Tom Bliss: But, essentially, I think the first thing i've ever done an R it was a class I took an undergrad and,
Tom Bliss: It was I just you can do a project kind of in whatever you want, and I just said, oh i'm interested in getting something in basketball i'm interested in basketball i'm gonna just do something and,
Tom Bliss: If you do something that you're interested in with with our, the more you do it,
Tom Bliss: it's going to be easier for you to keep at it, because you're going to be interested in the results are going to be interested in the project and then,
Tom Bliss: By the end you're going to get a little bit better, and if you keep doing stuff like that that that's interesting to you eventually you're going to get,
Tom Bliss: very comfortable with it and it's not easy, I definitely didn't learn our overnight, and all this code took,
Tom Bliss: I mean, I think i've probably been using it for maybe five six years now, all of it took like a lot of practice, but anyone can can get there, as long as they have to keep at it keep practicing and keep getting better,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Some Thank you and I was just adding into the chat as well i'd see a few people are sharing really helpful links,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Also on the are for data science online learning community and just put this the slack link to join, we do have a sports analytics channel there which can be a great place for people to connect after the fact, as well, and like share resources there to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): amelia I see you have an another question that's been uploaded a bit as well, can I have you ask that one live too,
Amelia Probst: Sure um so I was just curious if you took into account, like the number of start to player had like on a kickoff return, for example, and how,
Amelia Probst: That went out in your model and the accuracy of it,
Tom Bliss: yeah um again, I mean this was kind of a bit of a simplification sort of a quick thing, and I would,
Tom Bliss: Maybe sound like a broken record, I would just I would say that, like, I have not, and I think that's, something that would be interesting to look at so,
Tom Bliss: Definitely if you're thinking about a big data submission, including trying that with with your model or building off of what I did here and adding that is definitely something to think about,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And Stephen Hill, I see that you had asked a question in the zoom chat earlier on vertical positioning data, do you want to jump in and add some context there,
Stephen Hill: Sure, I think I think Tom might have addressed that but definitely would be great to have vertical positioning data, but you know I think you mentioned that you didn't have it, but it might be able to be inferred,
Tom Bliss: yeah that's what I would say, and honestly I guess how I would suggest doing it is there was an event tagging of when a kickoff or when a pun was,
Tom Bliss: Like occurred or when a field goal was kicked it even if you can, if the event tag is off, you can kind of infer based on when you see the ball start to move in a given direction,
Tom Bliss: I would use that combined with the pfs hang time variable and you can figure out how long it was in the air um and everything Maybe you can and and,
Tom Bliss: If you don't even maybe we can just do it using the hang time variable and Canada, you can actually just use the hank pym variable and kinematics to get a sense of what the Z coordinate is because it's not to get to physics see here, but we can assume that gravity is constant,
Tom Bliss: And you can figure out if it's in the air for this long and then it will feel a constant acceleration of gravity and then eventually it will,
Tom Bliss: Like like you can figure out like if it wasn't there for this long you know what gravity is you know it had to have reach this Z height,
Tom Bliss: And then you can tie that to the time and then, once you tied to the time you can get an x and a y so um I would I would Google kinematics and there's a way to him for doing that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, I am I see a few people that also asked her about where the recording will be shared to just shared a few helpful links there, we do have,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Tomorrow off at RStudio but i'll share the recording by Friday afternoon to the studio YouTube and I put the link there in the chat and then also on the meetup page and and on linkedin to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And Tom are you getting kicked out yet,
Tom Bliss: I don't think so so yeah i'm,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Okay awesome there's a anonymous question that was was positioning of cameras on the field for video capture and important factor for this,
Tom Bliss: Yes, so as I, as I might have said at the beginning, there are several leagues, including nba nhl I think and,
Tom Bliss: soccer that use video tracking data on the nfl isn't one of them it's based off chips that are located in the shoulder pads of each player and in the ball so camera angles, what was not a factor in this at all it's it's more based on a real like a signal from the chips to the processor,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): hey Thank you and I see a few more questions are coming in, on the zoom chat as well i'm dying my bestest to organize them from the slide Oh, but feel free to raise your hand if there's a question i've missed, and you want to ask live to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): see someone,
Tom Bliss: I was gonna say someone asked stadium nets are standard, the question, yes, they are but sorry go ahead,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Okay perfect and other question anonymous question was how does hang time work with onside kick off, is there any description or data around the type of role bounce of onside kicks,
Tom Bliss: yeah let me, let me try to think so in the PF data, I would suggest looking at kick contact type for onside kicks um I don't know again pfs is,
Tom Bliss: I don't know the data that data like that, like as well, maybe, as I know, the tracking data, but I would try to check that,
Tom Bliss: i'm pretty sure the hang time would just be how long until the definition is how long and once the ball goes into the air, how long until touch the ground,
Tom Bliss: Obviously, as some would know with onside kick sometimes you will get into the air and then have it land and then bounce so that the hang time will be rather low,
Tom Bliss: So, in that sense, it might be a little bit difficult to figure out exactly what's going on with like the Z coordinate on onside kicks assuming it it,
Tom Bliss: If there is a bounce um, but I would try look at chick contact type arm, in addition to hang time and kick contact type are probably your best bet but Admittedly, it might be,
Tom Bliss: Information that's hard to get,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thanks Sam I see there's also some conversation going on in the chat around Williams or wilbert question around what are good free nfl data sets that are available to the public and can be used,
Tom Bliss: Absolutely yeah,
Tom Bliss: yeah yeah so um nfl faster as a package that has a lot of really good free data sets, and I think a lot of questions, I think I might have seen on on Twitter and and the keg of discussion page before we're like oh,
Tom Bliss: How do we figure out who the fumbling player is how do we do it and and honestly I would, I would just suggest using nfl faster and they merge very easily to the data that we're providing to merge on game ID employee ID,
Tom Bliss: So that that's something I would recommend um I would recommend, I mean the weather data that I provided also you can use with game idiom play it if that's of interest um,
Tom Bliss: yeah I think those would probably be the main two but um there are tons of stuff out there, and you have the package that involvement wrote it could also be helpful,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Wonderful I think we made it to the end of the slide oh questions, but I just want to do a,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): double check from the slack here and I see,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Matthew you asked is there a way to access the chat transcript after the meeting,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I will go through that and then copy at the links and i'll share that in the YouTube recording and then in the like on the meetup discussion page two,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And i'm not sure if anybody some i'm allowed to download the chat you might be able to if you see three dots you can press save my just only be available to me,
Tom Bliss: And Tom mark, I think, said something I would definitely agree looking at an Fo reader,
Tom Bliss: yeah should, I think nfl fast enough or Rita are connected, but I would absolutely recommend looking at reader to his nfl pastor I think it's better for live data but yeah and if a reader also is a good one,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): it's going to open it up if anybody wants to raise their hand and ask a question if five unfortunately missed something from earlier or, if you have a new question you'd like to ask, before we end today,
Zac Rogers: i've got a question if it's possible to ask,
Zac Rogers: Sure, I was wondering with punt returns and kick returns, is it possible to,
Zac Rogers: Perhaps expected yards over expect sorry expected yards,
Zac Rogers: Rushing yards ever expected and he's the nfl they that's available that they already have from models before or would we have to build ourselves,
Tom Bliss: I would i'm guessing this is Mike Lopez on he's probably a better person to ask, but I think it,
Tom Bliss: Probably in here so let's go Mike good,
Michael Lopez: yeah I think that your best two steps back are the initial,
Michael Lopez: expected you rushing yards on cargo from the 2020 big data will that that framework is there, I think probably more actively in terms of copying and pasting code,
Michael Lopez: And then baldwin who Tom mentioned earlier, he looked at using that same framework with definitive coverage games so like man vs own, and I want to say his code is public,
Michael Lopez: Those are those are your two best bets I wouldn't be surprised if somebody this year goes and also replicates it if you're trying to be that person, you know I think those two those two places would be where to go,
Michael Lopez: and get started there,
Zac Rogers: In for much of course,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you i'll open it up to you, any other remaining questions, too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): i'm so bad at silence, but I tried to wait at least six or seven seconds,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Well, thank you all so much for joining, and thank you, Tom that was amazing I really appreciate your time and sharing all your insights with us,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I just a reminder will share all the links in the recording up to the studio YouTube and on the meetup page and on linkedin, but if you ever have any questions at all or can't find something feel free to reach out to me,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): You just email me Rachel at RStudio COM or on meetup and linkedin,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you so much, Tom,
Tom Bliss: Thank you, thanks everyone for listening today,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Have a great rest of the day, everyone,